[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
افاده مراسلنا بان مقاتلات حربيه احليه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شنت غارات
استهدفت موقعا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع غزه وقال شهود عيان
ان الطائرات الاسرائيليه استهدفت الموقع
باكثر من 10 صواريخ ما اسفر عن وقوع اضرار
ماديه كبيره دون اصابات كما ادى القصف
الانقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن مناطق عده
وسط القطاع وقال المتحدث باسم جيش
الاحتلال انها طائرات حربيه هاجمت موقعا
تابعا لحركه حماس وان القصف جاء ردا على
عمليات اطلاق قضاء فصاروخيه من غزه مساء
الخميس
اما حركه حماس فقد وصفت القصف الاسرائيلي
على قطاع غزه لانه عدوان سافر وامتداد
للحرب المفتوحه على الفلسطينيين واقل
الناطق باسم الحركه حازم قاسم في بيان
انما سماه الارهاب الصهيونيه لن يوقفه
ثوره الشعب الفلسطيني المتصاعده هذا واقله
كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري للحركه ان
القذف الاسرائيليه استهدف موقعا لها وسط
قطاع غزه
نجى رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق
عمران خان من محاوله اغتيال خلال التجمع
لانصاره في مدينه
باقليم الانجاب قال حزب وانصاف الذي
يتزحمه ان موكبه تعرض لاطلاق رصاص اصابه
في قدمه نقدم مراسلنا عن مصدر في الحسبه
ان احد المهاجمين
معتوقل الثاني واذان رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني شريف محاوله الاغتياله وطلب
وزير الداخليه بتقديم تقرير فوريه عن
الحادث
قال المجلس الاقليمي في خير سنوننا القوات
الروسيه ازالت علمها عن المبنى الحكومي
الرئيسي واعاده موضوعها في المقاطعه الى
جنوب نهر دنبرو وخفضت عدد جنودها من جهته
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويس اوستن ان
الاوكرانيين قادرون على استعاده خرسون من
الروس
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صدم محاولات
هجوميه اوكرانيه في خيرسون وتدمير مستودعا
للاسلحه في المقاطعه واسقاط مروحيه عسكريه
اوكرانيه
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه ثلاثه صواريخ
بالسياح باتجاه بحر اليابان وكانت بيونج
يونج اطلقت يوم الاربعاء اكثر من عشره
صواريخ من ساحليها شرقي والغربيه كما اعلن
سلاح الجو الكوري الجنوبي انه سيمدد
المناورات الجويه المشتركه مع الامريكيين
ونقلت رويترز عن مصادر الدبلوماسيه
بينها الولايات المتحده دعت لاجتماع بمجلس
الامن بشانه كوريا
انت هذا الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]